when you don't teach money in school
what happens
what happens well maybe
this explains why millennials
absolutely suck at managing their money
let's get into this next story which is
a business insider story and this
shocked me because a couple weeks ago we
did a story on how 40 of americans
making over a hundred thousand dollars
live paycheck to paycheck 40 of
americans
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
live paycheck to paycheck that's
individuals not household incomes that's
individuals we also discussed that only
15 percent of americans make a hundred
thousand dollars or more so there's ten
of you in a room
eight and a half of you are not making
hundred grand or more so one in one and
a half of you are making a hundred grand
so it's not like it's that common to
make a hundred grand is my point right
but for the millennials that are making
a hundred a grand
sixty percent of millennials earning a
hundred grand or more a year say they're
living paycheck to paycheck so this
epidemic of personal finance and not
understanding what to do with your money
it does not it's not immune to america
it's everywhere the millennials they
take the cake
they're taking the cake and eating it to
60 percent of these millennials live in
paycheck to paycheck so here's the story
here on business insider saying
basically saying these high earning
millennials feel broke now could it be
some of their lifestyle choices
marcelo
i'd say yes i guarantee it's because of
their lifestyle
they're making a hundred thousand
dollars a lot of them are not married
okay they got no kids your millennials
are basically the oldest i call myself
the oldest millennial okay
40 years old now right that's the oldest
millionaire the youngest millennials
probably 25 years old so the average
millennials late 20s early 30s average
people are waiting to get married so a
lot of these millennials making 100
grand a year
they don't have expenses like normal
people do like the baby boomers do or
the gen x's do when i'm married a lot of
people are married i also argue that it
was harder to spend money back then
it is so easy to spend money today
you can tap your phone two times five
hundred dollars are gone
it's over yeah you know what i mean uber
eats these these kids are these kids are
not even leaving their house to get food
if you let me ask you something if a
baby boomer at in his day and age had
the power to press a button and have a
guy get him food do you think they'd
have the same financial stability they
have today it's easier certainly easier
than ever right now
but let's get into this story and then
we can do some of our favorite banter
anyway this is such a problem with
millennials these hundred thousand
dollar making millennials
that
they've actually come up to for a
nickname for these people it's such a
pervasive problem
that it they said we got to give a
nickname to these people you know what
they've called these people they call
them henry's
henry's and why do they call them
henry's henry stands for high earner
not rich yet hi earner not rich yet
h-e-n-r-y
because you're broke henry so henry's
typically fall victim to something that
we covered last time in the podcast
which is called lifestyle creep creep it
on the comet which is basically when
your
wants
become your needs
right you might be driving a 2014 honda
accord it's going fine
but i want that new bmw
you might have a decent watch
i want that new rolex i need that new
rolex right i want to go out for a nice
dinner but i need to go to prime 112 in
miami the most expensive restaurant i
need it i need it i need it i'm making
100 g's
but what happens marcelo they start
living paycheck to paycheck if you were
if you were making a hundred thousand
dollars a year would you marcelo be
living a paycheck to paycheck i don't
know dude i have a friend of mine uh who
is just really into money and he's
always preaching to save that money
i mean none stop he doesn't do
alone about it so i might i might not i
might have a little plan in place i have
a feeling the people watching this show
yeah are on my camp yeah some of them
let me know below if you're willing to
make a comment how much you make a year
and if you feel like being you know
lying to us
you know add ten percent on top of it
all good but don't double it i'd like to
know what we're working with a year
that'd be great to know okay
it's basically not that everyone says a
hundred grand you know it's gonna all
they're all be lying because only you
know eight and a half people out of ten
sorry one and a half people out of ten
make 100 grand a year so i'd like to
know what's going on here so who's a
henry out there
be very honest in the comments so
basically
the problem is you make you're making
six figures and what we talked about you
should be good you should be as i call
chillin the problem is
the kids did the hard part they earned
the money
and they should be making enough to not
only survive but to thrive the problem
is making money is only half
the battle the other half of the battle
is knowing what to do with the money
having offense and defense we talked
about this last time
where
with with money it's not just the amount
of money you make which is your offense
is the amount of money that goes out the
door which is your defenses your
expenses right
so every year
in the nfl or in the nba there's going
to be a team that leads the league in
offense and they might suck on defense i
use this analogy of the phoenix suns
steve nash amari stottemeyer sean mary
and the whole you know leandro barbosa
they led the team in scoring scored 125
points a game problem was they gave up
126. that's what's happening with these
henry's is millennials making a hundred
thousand dollars a year is they're
making a hundred grand and they're
probably spending 110 because they're
thinking that the good times won't stop
but you know something about the good
times
they don't last forever right and i
think it's also they're rushing you
always talk about how you're going to be
30 you're going to be 40 you're going to
be 50. yeah a lot of people maybe don't
realize that and they you know they
think i got to live for the now oh that
yolo mentality yeah that's that that's
what's hurting them a little bit too i
mean remember we grew up on yolo you
know you know baby boomers they got yolo
later in life i grew you know these
millennials they grew up on yolo drake
was a big deal for us yeah it's a big
deal
that's the motto yolos
how many millennials had yolo in their
bio at some point moment in time in
their life a lot of them marcelo do me a
favor read some of these uh incomes all
right starting with michael lopez if you
scroll up yeah josh lang is making 55
read the read some of these things we
got 52 50 undress hernandez 500k ngai
h-a-n
um ng 90k 70k 95k 45k
82k from jose aguilera david duarte
doing great um
sachadi shinde 139k
trc turtle lighting 150k samuel teddy 40
thousand dollars fabian paris said he's
19 years old that doesn't have really
anything to do with this but
that's fair i appreciate you fabian just
telling us your age it's good that he's
here right at that age learning about
money learn it good earning
70k i got cheap rent expensive car and
expensive food travel is a must
um you know and at the end of the day i
still feel short on cash i mean that
tells you everything you got to know huh
he got the expensive car expensive food
and travel is a must chris martinez
maybe you should you know take it back a
notch save a little money maybe you'll
this lifestyle creep seems to be
happening to him huh
um fabian pairs there he goes 32k at 19
years old and uh david said he's making
140k salary so i'd say we'd average it
out i mean it's pr we got a little bit
of everything here
yeah we do and respect to the people out
there making money and respect to the
people that are
they're just telling us the truth thank
you you're only lying to yourself if
you're making these comments i don't you
know whether you're making 80 grand or
60 grand or 120 grand i don't care
congratulations obviously there's only
two ways to have more money there's two
ways right you can make more
or you can spend less that's it offense
and defense so there it is right there
and you know that they say
is that only 20
of personal finance and money management
is knowledge
right knowledge can only take you so far
the other 80
behavioral we all know
that you should have a budget right we
all know that debt especially high
interest debt is bad we all know save
that money i've been saying it for five
years straight million times a day
okay we all know that you should invest
where should you invest i don't know the
riskier stuff it has a higher reward the
less risky stuff lower we all know that
we're all familiar with crypto we all
know the stock market we all know real
estate we know these things are just are
you doing them so that's the bottom line
so
put it this way if you're making 20 30
40 grand i've been there i've been that
guy okay it's not easy it's not easy get
a roommate okay limit your expenses and
start to make more money okay amen
if you're making a hundred grand a year
if you're making 500 grand a year i've
also been there
understand that you might not always
make that income not everything works
out forever
and
you know make sure that you have a
budget and that you're paying off your
debt and you're saving your vet you're
doing everything we talked about and if
you're making less than 100k a year but
you're not living paycheck to paycheck
you're doing something right you're
doing something right i always see this
all the time i'd rather
make
50 grand a year and save 10 5 000 and
start saving and investing and doing all
that then making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and spending it all of it
and every year i wind up what i wonder
why i have no money anyway
my advice to you henry's out there is
get it together
get it together because
it happened in 2008
it happened in 2020 you never know
what's going to happen next and that's
the reason that you save for the long
term because you might be 20 now but
you're going to be 30 and it might be 30
now you might be 40. the good times
don't last forever and use that saving
and use that compound interest the
eighth wonder of the world to grow your
money anyway marcelo final thoughts
before we move on here um you know
lifestyle creep is real a lot of people
are noticing it and um nothing man uh
try not to live that yolo lifestyle
believe it or not probably drake himself
doesn't live that your life so he
probably saving a lot of money doing a
lot of investing
that is very true and um marcelo you're
24 now 24 years old 24 years old yeah
the future looks bright for you buddy
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken